PROFESSOR: Let me discuss, for
a second, effective potential.
And-- actually, let me ask you
a question to get you started.
We're going to look at high n.
N-- so n's, say, 100.
And then l will go
from 0 up to 99.
Very high l's.
What's going to be
different from them?
Well here is one
possibility, and that's
a possibility that happens.
The orbits are going to go
from being circular to being
elliptical as you change l.
And I ask you--
which l would correspond
to circular orbit,
and which l would correspond
to the most elliptical orbit?
So let's take a poll/
so most circular orbit--
is it l equals 0 or l equals 99?
Who votes for l equals 0
for the most circular orbit?
I have about half [INAUDIBLE],
a little bit more than half.
OK.
Who votes for l equals 99?
[INAUDIBLE]
Which is the most [INAUDIBLE]?
OK, this is funny,
because we all
associate most
circular with l equals
0, spherically symmetric.
But it's wrong.
This is the most circular.
AUDIENCE: What if l equals 100?
PROFESSOR: You cannot
reach l equal 100.
Actually-- and this
is most elliptical.
and you can have the
intuition for that.
Let's avoid the calculation
and be intuitive.
And the intuition it is kind
of interesting, because we
said at effective potential.
And indeed, I want to discuss--
that's what I want
to understand.
Effective potential.
So maybe I'll draw this
line a little lower.
And what is the
effective potential?
We've written it
already many times.
It's h squared l times l
plus 1 over 2mr squared
minus e squared over r.
So the minus e squared
over r is here.
Maybe I should draw it in a
way that gives me more room.
Like that.
OK.
And then there is the energy
level that I'm looking at.
It's some high energy level.
So I'll put it near
here, not too near
that I don't see
it, but near here.
Here is-- my en is here.
OK.
So the answer is
actually already there.
Not too clearly, but here it is.
What does a particle
do in this potential?
It goes with lots of kinetic
energy, very fast here,
it goes from here to here.
Here to here.
But what does that mean?
That the radius is changing
from r to some other value of r.
From r equals 0 to
some other value of r.
So what looks like an orbit?
If you have a planet
going around the sun,
and at some point it
seems to reach the sun,
and at some point it goes far--
here is the sun--
then the orbit
must be like this.
That's likely to be the orbit.
On the other hand, as
soon s is equal to 1,
you have the part
of the contributions
that affect the potential.
You have a 1 over
r square like this.
And then the total
potential, which
is the original
term plus that, will
have something that looks
like this, and go like that.
And then this orbit is going to
go from some small value of r,
but different from
0, to another one.
So those are all
elliptical orbits,
because the radius
is not constant.
And then this orbit,
it goes like that.
Now look at it--
if you have some
elliptical orbit-- so then
after that time, it just
becomes a little more
like this, in which the minimum
radius for, say l equal 1
is here, and the maximum
radius has been reduced.
l equal 2, l equal 3, they
all produce different ones.
My graph is not perfect.
Different ones.
And finally, one
that just touches it.
And that one, the
radius is fixed.
The particle is
moving like that.
And that is your
spherical orbit.
And if you increase l a
little more, no more solution.
So it's the top
l that produces--
this is already almost circular,
and this is perfectly circular.
So then it goes like this, and
then eventually goes like this,
and finally at the
end it goes like that.
And it's circular
at the last case.
For the most l, you finally
get your circular orbit.
And also the intuition is clear.
If you have a
circular orbit, you
have lots of angular momentum--
r cross p is very good.
When two vectors are
orthogonal, the cross-product
of angular momentum is large.
But look here.
Here is r, for the
shortest orbit,
and p is in that direction.
R cross p almost like that.
This is a very low
angular momentum orbit.
So l equals 0 is the
most elliptical orbit.
L equal very high is
the most circular orbit.
There is one thing--
a calculation-- maybe I'll
use 10 minutes next time--
is to show that there's
two turning points here--
an r plus and an r minus.
So there is an r plus for
one solution, and an r minus,
and it goes like that.
So the r pluses
and the r minuses
corresponds to an ellipse that--
here is the center.
That's where the proton sits.
And you go r plus out is the
maximum, and r minus is here.
So the two turning points
that define the maximum r
and minimum r tell
you about the lips
on these r plus plus r minus.
And when you find those critical
points and do the calculation,
you in fact can show
that r plus plus r minus
is indeed equal
to n squared a 0.
I think that number
comes out exactly there.
R plus plus r minus over 2.
The average is exactly that.
So the roots, the two roots,
are such that their average
is always the same.
So this is not--
I'm not sure I get it
right with my graph,
but it should be
that if you take
the average of that
intersection points,
they're always at
the same point.
And so that's how it
happens under an analog in--
so you get the intuition here.
Here are your orbits.
And these are
equal energy orbits
of different eccentricity
as you go in there.
And even Kepler knew that,
because Kepler figured out
that the time that it takes
the planet to go around
depends only on the sum of these
two things, the major diameter.
So all these
solutions over here--
if they were planets--
would take the same time
to go around the sun.
So they all, in
quantum mechanics,
have the same energy, and
they're therefore degenerate.
So the mystery of the
quadratic potential
that makes all of these
periods to be the same
is the mystery that is making
the energies the same in all
of these orbits.
So we'll finalize
this story next time
and do some other fun things.